medidas drásticas contra las
organizaciones religiosas vinculadas a
Rusia un anuncio hecho por el presidente
bolodimir zenenski en su discurso
nocturno
el Consejo de Seguridad nacional y
defensa ha dado instrucciones al
gobierno para que proponga al parlamento
un proyecto de ley sobre la prohibición
de las actividades en Ucrania de las
organizaciones religiosas afiliadas a
los centros de influencia de la
federación rusa
de la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana apoyada
por Rusia conocida como el patriarcado
de Moscú tenía derecho a operar en uno
de los lugares más sagrados de Ucrania
el complejo de pechers
un lugar que fue asaltado la semana
pasada por las fuerzas ucranianas en un
intento de contrarrestar lo que se
considera actividades subversivas de los
servicios especiales rusos el líder de
la iglesia ortodoxa el patriarca quiril
ha expresado su apoyo a Putin y a la
guerra
de defensa en el mundo ruso el mundo
ruso no es solo Rusia sino que está en
todos los lugares en los que vive la
gente que ha sido educada en las
tradiciones de la ortodoxia quien las
tradiciones de la moral rusa un hecho
que ha provocado divisiones en mayo una
parte de la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana
rompió sus lazos con Rusia debido a la